[Music]
it's called ransomware hackers holding
your information hostage in order to
make you pay up now there's a new group
getting in on the online crime wave and
it seems they'll target just about
anyone
a new ransomware operation named omega
targets organizations and businesses
worldwide in double extortion attacks
demanding millions in ransom ransomware
is when you have a cyber criminal or
somebody else that essentially is able
to hack into your system this one just
started in may hackers are just getting
going here omega hackers threaten to
disclose the attack to business partners
if a ransom is not paid they start
encrypting your data that you have on
your computer last year hackers targeted
the software of 5 000 schools if hackers
are breaking through a business firewall
the impact can be felt company-wide
compromises their their servers all of
their data all their customers files
their employee files
another recent attack in ohio a business
breach affected nearly 5 thousand people
their credit card numbers all lifted
they encrypt that data sometimes they'll
exfiltrate it meaning that they send it
to their server so they save a copy of
it and then what they'll do is they'll
use that to extort money from you
the message is clear pay the ransom or
we keep the data and then if you refuse
to pay that ransom then the next thing
they'll do is they'll try to blackmail
you and say hey look if you don't give
us 500 000
then we're also going to release all of
this personal identifying information of
your customers and your employees on the
dark web and give it to all the
criminals that are out there to protect
you and your team experts recommend
multi-factor authentication updating
software restricting admin privileges
and provide online security training for
all staff
well for more tips on how you and your
family and your business can stay safe
online go to our website
eightnewsnow.com and click on cybersafe
parent right under the news tab